your hand Sarah Dr Sarah nulani ahia has
gathered a group of doctors nurses and
mental health counselors in a car park
just outside the official exclusion Zone
that's been set up around Lahaina this
is going to be a month plan is to drive
a convoy through the military
checkpoints guarding the area to help
those who've not evacuated West and Maui
and to supplement federal aid efforts
they're starting to realize that they
don't have the resources the capacity or
the relationships in the community to
really effectively meet those needs and
and it's the people coming together
taking care of each other as we've
always done here in Hawaii the Convoy
drives through the burnt out Devastation
of Lahaina this area remains closed off
as the search continues for human
remains what becomes clear is how
although the core of Lahaina has been
destroyed life goes on in close
proximity all around it even though
water electricity and Communications
have been cut off for many the Medics
Convoy ended up here in the central area
where relief is being coordinated for
those in the area who either can't leave
or don't want to leave there's a full
neighborhood of people who just don't
want to leave for obvious reasons the
way I understand it is that at a certain
point if they were to leave they
wouldn't be let back out it's something
that we've heard from so many who fled
the area the suspicion that rebuilding
Lahaina may not be as benign a process
as the governor and other officials say
it will be we've been removed constantly
over and over and over by the
plantations now by the over development
by the tourist industry now we have this
disaster and there's all this open land
it's like people are seeing dollar signs
somebody said yesterday lahain is going
to be the new Wailea which is you know a
very sort of fancy moneyed area on the
south side and I have to say it I'll be
over my dead body
by standing there ground here and
through mutual Aid the community is
planting a marker in the ground
hancy Al Jazeera kanapali Maui